now to campaign 2012 adda are already
casting early votes ahead of this
Saturday's caucus it's the next event in
the presidential race the newest poll
shows Bernie Sanders leading Joe Biden
by 7 points with four other contenders
bunched up behind them most of them are
focusing on a rival who will not be on
the ballot that is former New York Mayor
Mike Bloomberg the billionaire and
former Republican is getting hit over
his record and his surge of campaign
spending chief Washington correspondent
major Garrett joins us major good
morning so good morning he's not even
running in Nevada or South Carolina so
why all the attention on Bloomberg well
as we're learning such things happen
when you spend more than 400 billion
dollars on ads an organization but skip
the first four contests and rise in the
polls anyway
ten days ago roughly Democrat spoke of
unity back then that meant not attacking
each other now apparently it means
joining forces against Mike Bloomberg
the American people are sick and tired
of billionaires buying a buckets
Bloomberg's approach seeks to turn the
nomination process with its emphasis on
early contests and momentum building on
its head jobs creator leader problem
solver he's on track to spend more than
415 million dollars before Super Tuesday
that's when he'll be on ballots for the
first time and where he hopes to vault
into contention for the Democratic
nomination I think he cannot hide but
behind the airwaves and the money
Bloomberg is also facing criticism for
his support of stop and frisk he has
apologized for the anti-crime tactic
that allowed police to search suspects
without a warrant from 2011 to 2012 more
than 80 percent of those stopped were
black or Latino nearly 90 percent were
found to be innocent 60 billion dollars
can buy a lot of advertising but a
cantillation record Bloomberg is also
under fire for lawsuits filed over the
years alleging that he created a culture
of sexual harassment at his company in a
statement the Bloomberg campaign
responded quote Mike simply does not
tolerate any kind of discrimination or
harassment we in our party hold
ourselves to the highest standard and it
is going to be critical for us to have a
nominee who can authentically lead
to the president Kellyanne Conway seized
on Bloomberg's past comments on
stop-and-frisk the philosophy was to
castigate and denigrate people of color
ignoring president Trump's support for
the practice which he advocated for in
Chicago in 2018 stop and frisk it works
and it was meant for problems like
Chicago it was meant for it stop and
frisk it's worth noting after Vice
President Joe Biden Bloomberg has
garnered more congressional black
support than any other candidate in the
race Bloomberg has until midnight
tomorrow to qualify for Wednesday
night's debate in Las Vegas his campaign
says it is hopeful he will make it on
that debate stage Anthony okay major
thank you